يومان بعد اصدار المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
مذكره توقيف بحقه حرس الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين على الرد بطريقته الخاصه
انه حر طليق اكثر من اي وقت مضى بل هو
اكثر اطمئنانا رغم وجوده بعيدا عن موسكو
ها هو بنفسه يقود السياره في ماريوبل شرق
اوكرانيا التي وصلها فجاه تحت جنح الظلام
يجوب شوارع المدينه شبه المقفره ويتحدث
الى بعض الماره يزور اسره في منزلها
ويتحدث مع افرادها ثم يعرج على مسرح
موسيقي اعيد بنائه ويستمع الى تقارير عن
اعمال اعاده اعمار المدينه المنكوبه اصر
الكريم على وصف جوله بوتين بالعفويه لكن
التحركات الرئيس في ماريوبل اثار
التساؤلات عما اذا كانت زياره خاطفه تحتمل
كل تلك الرسائل والمعاني بالنسبه
للاوكراني فان اختيار بوتين المجيئه ليلا
يؤكد مخاوفه الامنيه كما ان الليل يخفي
مشاهد الدمار والخراب في المدينه الساحليه
الاستراتيجيه التي دمرها الجيش الروسي في
بدايات حربه على اوكرانيا
اخضاع ماريوبول فتح الطريق امام موسكو
وسلطات المواليه لها للتمدد اكثر للسيطره
على نحو 60 في المئه من مقاطعه دونسك
شرقيه اوكرانيا ومن ثم بسط السيطره بشكل
اوسع على اكثر من 90% من لوغانسك التي
تشكل مع دونيسك اقليم دومباس ثم جاءت
الاستفتاءات المثيره للجدل والتي بمقتضاها
ضمت موسكو
بمقاطعتيه الى اراضيها اضافه الى التي
تسيطر على ثلثيها وخيرسون التي يقع نحو
75% منها تحت سيطره الجيش الروسي
لم يعترف المجتمع الدولي بتلك الاستفتاءات
لكن موسكو تمضي قدما في ترتيباتها تماما
كما فعلت في شبه جزيره القرم التي زارها
بوتين في الذكرى التاسعه لالحاقها بروسيا
في مثل هذه الايام من عام 2014